servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem video in dem wir mal heute nicht
pvp spielen
ich zeige euch heute meine top fünf
schilder in der micro version 1.9 denn
es gibt für die 19
das ist ziemlich cool und erspart ihm
viel arbeit und unordnung jetzt die
möglichkeit mit opti fein auch direkt
den shader model ihren das heißt man
braucht nicht mehr separat den gls e sls
oder gll gdl den mord auf jeden fall
immer für scheider früher man braucht
dazu installieren der ist jetzt in ob
die fein drin in gewissen version unter
anderem in der version die ich euch
unten verlinkt haben einfach optimal
installiert für die version bahn und
dann sieht das hier so aus noch mal
langsam optionen grafikeinstellungen und
eines toten shader werde die version
korrekt installiert habt soll aber kein
tutorial sein wie man das installiert
jeder der mal optifast hat weiß wie das
geht einfach die micro version einmal
starten kurz öffnen da wird dass es mal
gespielt habt dann wir schließen
ob die von installieren dann habt ihr
super easy ja und dann könnt ihr euch im
shaker herunterladen und in den shader
packs ordner im punkt minecraft
reinpacken
ok genug gelagert wir starten mit platz
fünf das ist der mister mit shader v 05
medium bevor ich mal auf den ihr eingehe
möchte ich noch kurz sagen welche
spezifikationen mein system hat das
heißt welche grafikkarte und so weiter
habe ich damit jetzt ein bisschen
vergleichen könnt mit eurem ich habe
eine gtx 67 nvidia geforce 16gb traum
davon 5 gb minecraft zugeteilt und einen
intel i7
prozessor wie fliegen durch die gegend
es ist jetzt schon nacht hier in dieser
welt wo kurz mal tag gemacht ja so sieht
das bei tag aus relativ heller shader
nicht zu erlesen und mein schatten ist
ganz gut gemacht so wie gesagt das sind
jetzt die keine ultra shader sondern das
ist auch ein medium eben weil ich nicht
so eine krasse maschine habe und weil
ich es auch im pvp noch gerne benutzen
möchte erstmal das ding wir schon mal
kurz das wasser heran
sehr nett also generell wasser ist bei
den meisten schülern immer eine
augenweide arbeiten aber nochmal kräftig
das ist was wir an mister mit voll gut
gefällt die wie fackeln hier im mystery
trader wirken dass es echt cooles so
leicht rötlich gerade hier bisschen raus
und rötlich bronze nach farbton wert
kein licht der charme kopf der lichter
piste ja im allgemeinen sehr solider
shader wir testen noch mal kurz im pvp
aus dazu sind wir auf dem hd und spielen
die runde quick es geht in der lobby so
ein bisschen dunkler aus er ist auch
hier ein bisschen dunkler die schatten
aber ist es auf jeden fall spielbar und
vor allem habe ich hier bei 100 fps 100
wir bleiben so um die 100 fps das ganz
praktisch so dass der erste gegner ua
keiner lag ist auf den fall spieler
würde ich sagen ja gut das war jetzt
nicht so glorreich aber es passt auf
jeden fall die spielbarkeit ist da würde
ich sagen weil er zu platz vier
platz vier ist der sie durchs weiteren
shader v 1.10
und das ist ein ziemlich heller ziemlich
man könnte fast sagen greller shader
sieht hier zum singleplayer zumindest so
aus aber das ist wichtig für pvp weil
die pvp maps meistens nicht so gut
ausgeleuchtet sind deswegen wird man
damit keine helligkeit probleme bekommen
das sehen wir auch gleich die
beleuchtung kommt nicht mehr so intensiv
durch über mister man noch ein bisschen
rötlich ich glaube der hat immer noch
kein licht
der charme kommt schenken immer nicht
alles klar jetzt hast du auch nicht sehr
gut sonst weiter im text fliegen
bisschen über die ebene das jetzt gerade
mit 86 ps als wenn hier neue chance
gerendert werden müssen dann sehen wir
da hängt das ein bisschen hat die fps
halten sich so dass es nicht ruckeln
also für nach dem absolut spieler würde
ich sagen
hier das wasser sieht sehr schön aus
kommt man hier das leicht gekräuselte
als gefällt guck mal hier wunderbar hier
kommt es besonders gut wenn man hier
durch die gegend fliegt das ist auch
schon ein großer dicker schwerer das
wasser sieht hammer aus sieht ein
bisschen aus wie basti obsidian so aus
den winkel ist extrem dunkel wirkt fest
von außen wenn man genau hinschaut sieht
man dass es sich aber bewegt auch die
perspektive aus dem wasser raus ist echt
cool wollen wie man durchs wasser schaut
wo war das so geil aus guck mal das ist
das ist eine richtig schöne perspektive
hammer also gefällt schönes wasser
schöne farben sehr ordentlichen mal
gucken aus einem pvp kann
wir sind auch wir hier wieder in der
lobby die schilder leuchten so ein
bisschen es wirkt ähnlich bisschen
dunkler jetzt auch hier in der runde hat
man da hinten paar schatten die jetzt
nicht unbedingt so intensiv ausfallen
müssen aber alles allem passt das schon
ganz gut würde ich sagen so jetzt kann
man sich hier kunst ok so what ever was
ist das okay für uns überhaupt gibt es
nicht
ich spiele auf jeden fall mal hat seinen
leichten blattränder wenn man drauf
schaut es sich ein bisschen verwischt an
den rändern ist aber sehr dezent für ein
echt cooler shader auf jeden fall auch
perfekt zum abstauben geeignet ja das
passt auf jeden fall ist ein sauberes
ding ja das ist cool
also ja ist auch im pvp sehr ordentlich
der gefährlichen bisschen besser als der
andere muss ich sogar sagen
so aber sei heute kein display werden
deswegen weiter zum dritten platz
das ist der ruhr place shader und der
bildschirm singleplayer auch ziemlich
geil wie immer heißt es dann dass wir
nachher im pvp deutlich heller deutlich
bessere sichtbarkeit mit sich bringt so
hier im player wirkt schon sehr hell
muss man sein ein sehr kräftiges blau
der sand ist fast fast weiß denn
normalerweise brown ist das grün kommt
auch ganz gut durch ging hier mit 132 ps
und einer menge junk updates also das
passt auf jeden fall hier lava und
wasser sind auch sehr schön das wasser
wasser ist immer der hammer die leute
geben die stufen über wasser das sieht
auch aus wie das will man einfach
ablenken
hier unten das wasser sehen ist ziemlich
schön hat ihr sohn leichten fehler drin
dass man ihn so kannten sie zwischen den
blöcken zerstört bis in den
gesamteindruck aber alles in allem ein
sehr sauberes ding ich finde hier zeigt
der route place seine stärke kommen hier
in der lobby sieht schon sehr gut aus
auch auf der map drauf sehr sehr gut
nicht zu dunkel
das ist dagegen gerade die stärken dass
udo place finde ich im pvp sehr gutes
ding hierfür für solche zwecke passt wie
gesagt er trägt nicht zu dick auf
dadurch dass er ein bisschen schlechter
ist kann man ihn auch sehr gut im pvp
nutzen wenn man sich nicht eine combo
fängt uns unerklärlichen gründen gefällt
auf jeden fall die sonne ist super super
nova es ist nicht zu crazy sodass man
schlechter spielen würde sehr gut für
pvp finde ich immer es geht nicht gegen
die sonne schaut so wie hier ist es
einfach ein ordentliches ding ich gehe
baden und wir springen zu platz nummer
zwei als nummer zwei ist der vision
kraft shader und der muss hier erstmal
eine ganze menge nach rändern der eine
kontinuierlich nach hier hat einen sehr
interessanten farbstich finde ich
natürlich auch hier movie cars
das spezial featuren invision krafträder
ist dass der einen autofokus hat ja das
gibt es wirklich
das ist der einzige fehler den ich
bisher mit autofokus gesehen habe dass
ich dann so aus achtet mal auf die
charaktere so wenn ich an der kasse
vorbei schaue ist die unscharfe jetzt
drauf wird die scharf seht ihr jetzt
achtet auf der intermot hintergrund
unscharf wenn ich die karte immer im
fokus absteiger den hintergrund sagt mit
der scharf seht ihr das das ist der
hammer an shader mit autofokus acht mal
darauf alles wird sofort schafft wenn
man drauf guckt
das ist wahrscheinlich der beste
autofokus sind jemals gab ansonsten soll
ein leichter gold stich wird sagen das
ist ein goldstück der mit ziemlich gut
gefällt wir schauen so war das wasser an
wasser ist relativ unspektakulär würde
ich sagen dass es ist ziemlich
unspektakulär
also wenn die packs davor und ziemlichen
wert aus wasser gelegt anscheinend ist
da hier das wasser nicht so wirklich den
fokus geraten da haben sie dieses geile
autofokus detail sehr schönes teil
wenn man wasser für die geste ist
vielleicht nicht der beste aber
nichtsdestotrotz schützt das auch den
vision kraft nicht davor im pvp getestet
zu werden deswegen sprechen darüber
kurz noch dass es meine persönliche
meinung zu diesen schildern dass manche
von euch damit nicht einverstanden sind
ist ganz normal ganz natürlich es geht
auch mehr darum euch die schilder
vorzustellen nicht zu sagen geht das ist
der beste und das schlechteste shader
von diesen fünf einfach ein bisschen zu
zeigen was die spender können hier so
sieht der vision kraft aus in der lobby
finde ich sieht sehr geil aus ein
bisschen dunkeln leichter blau oder grau
stich würde ich jetzt sagen aber sehr
sehr geil im gesamteindruck aber jetzt
geht's los
also man sieht schon der vision cloud
verändert ein bisschen nach die ganze
zeit das kann man störend empfinden bei
männern nicht ganz das gleiche bild hat
für mich ist es aber in ordnung würde
ich sagen wo man sich ja eh meistens
bewegt
auch im pvp absolut spielbare habe ich
generell auch darauf geachtet wir haben
deswegen heute keine ultra shader dabei
weil es mir wichtig war darauf zu achten
dass man nicht hätte ja auch alle im pvp
spielen kann wie gesagt hat ja am anfang
schon betont du hier nochmal der fps
testen habe ich gerade eben beim rudel
place vergessen
jawohl place läuft aber auch ziemlich
für sie mit 110 ps ungefähr
der legt jetzt hier bei 390 bis 90 ps
ungefähr kann man sagen manche nicht die
lobby laufe passt auf jeden fall
ausreichend flüssig um ordentlich pvp zu
spielen so und jetzt zu meinen absoluten
favoriten zu platz eins platz eins ist
jetzt muss ich ablesen ist ein ewig
langer name kv 6.1 punkt 1 3 beta shader
auch ein sehr sauberes ding aber das
wasser geht mal das wasser ist dass sie
einfach einzigartig aus ist ein bisschen
dunkler was auch daran lag dass es
gerade im nacht war so bei tag sieht der
shader immer noch hart aber trotz hat
diesen leichten etwas dunkleren stich
das wasser sieht sehr schön aus die
schatten entsprechend lang wenn die
sonne tief steht natürlich werde das ist
einfach geil ausfindig clearwater kann
bis auf den grund schauen aber trotzdem
noch eine sehr bewegte oberfläche das
grün kommt schön durch kräftige schatten
fast zu kräfte ich bin nicht so ein
krasser schatten fan aber das hier sieht
auch sehr geil ausfindig
auch ihr verhalten sehr sehr gutes ding
gerade das wasser reißt jeden fall für
mich raus wenn wir nochmal durch die
gegend fliegen kommen wir auf ziemlich
glatt 100 fps
so sieht das in der runde aus einen
leichten sonnenuntergang dem kloster
es ist ein bisschen dunkler wenn man da
drin einem gebäudes bond können fast ein
bisschen zu dunkel seien wir kommen hier
auf 80 74 ps also mit einer der
leistungsfähigsten shader so jetzt muss
er kurz mal unter der rüstung bedienen
dass man sich gerne in szene
oder holen sie auch nicht so hier
nochmal die lobby haben jetzt hier 70
fps in goma hub ist ein bisschen wie
gesagt arbeitsintensiver da kann man
auch mit meinen spex ein bisschen rein
bekommen aber ihr dass sie just mal
wieder das sonnenlicht durch fällt das
sieht einfach geil aus deswegen verdient
platz eins für mich auch in jeder
schädigend was richtig gutes hat seine
vision kraft mit dem
autofokus oder der who plays eigentlich
wie gemacht für pvp ist das war es so
weit von meiner scheder vorstellung ich
hoffe dadurch gefallen
die links zu allen schäden sind unten in
der beschreibung wenn die dann mal
download wenn davon überzeugt sein
ansonsten gerne feedback dazu was war
für euch der beste schüler aus der
vorstellung werde ich am besten gefallen
werde ich am wenigsten gefallen wenn wir
die am ersten pvp spielen wen am ersten
single player
das hat mich interessieren alles um rein
und dann sehen wir es beim nächsten
wieder biss dann hau rein machst ja